welcome to bananamores get your tissues
ready because you're gonna be crying
laughing at this next comedian
i will personally be using a
handkerchief
thanks mitzi it's so fantastic to be
here
it's really fantastic to be anywhere i'm
going to give you a minute
let you soak it up you're checking out
my haircut
you're looking at the necktie maybe it's
telling you something about me
maybe you're picking up the context
clues
if not i'll just tell you uh i swim in
the lady pond
do my hunting in the lady forest
i'm gay sir you looked confused
i love when i tell audiences that i'm
gay because i can see all the women are
like
oh okay and the men are like hell yes
now it's a show
men love lesbians i i don't know why
even my dad when i told him he stood
up he said hey she got that from me
which was a weird thing to say at church
but
he means well speaking of church we just
had a little
easter happen fantastic holiday easter
is a fat
kid's favorite holiday now a lot of
people will try to tell you that fat
kids love halloween
no no we don't because on halloween
y'all make us walk around for that candy
and on easter that rabbit hippity hops
it to your door
clearly a superior candy infused
holiday i did miss this year at easter
was visiting my nana
i love my nana y'all she is 88 years old
and one of the coolest women you will
ever meet in your life
and i love going over there y'all
because she's got a giant
tv she's got the biggest tv you've ever
i'm telling y'all they gave this woman
one inch of tv
for every year she's been alive and if
she is awake
the tv is on and the show that she keeps
it on
is family feud game show network all the
way
family feud we watch it morning noon and
night
and we one day we just we were up late
it was like 3
30 in the afternoon we couldn't take our
eyes off this particular episode
because the families were tied the
families are tied
the point value is tripled top three
answers are on the board
name something you put on a baked potato
nana stands up and screams aluminum foil
i mean she's not wrong but when the
number one answer was butter
she was mad when answers two and three
were sour cream and chives
she lost her mind y'all she stood up
i have been making baked potatoes since
1952.
okay i've made them without butter i've
made them without sour cream
i'm not entirely sure what the hell a
chive even is
but i have never in my life made a baked
potato without any damn aluminum foil
and then she just got up and went to bed
turned the tv off she was done with all
of us
she doesn't like it when i when i say
when i say hell
or dad those are she doesn't like those
words she still calls people turkey
that's how she gets mad at him and she
says don't you ever worry talking like
that i said listen
here's the truth it doesn't matter what
i say
somebody could get offended i i could
anything i could say anything in
somebody
i could be telling a joke about walmart
and somebody would say
that's not funny my mama was killed by
fallen christ
that's why that smiley face is wearing a
hard hat because of my mama
[Applause]
thanks so much y'all you've been
fantastic there's
no business like show business
incredible